-Not today, Ron.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker:
>> Tucker
>> Tucker: TILLMAN IS RUNNING
FOR CONGRESS IN COLORADO AS A
DEMOCRAT.
HE SAID PEPPER SPRAY SHOULD BE
ENOUGH TO STOP A SHOOTER AND TO
PROVE IT, HE PEPPER SPRAYED
HIMSELF.
>> TRUST ME.
THIS WILL STOP ANYONE IN THEIR
TRACKS.
>> ♪ ♪
NOW I CAN'T SEE ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: DON'T TRY THAT AT
HOME.
WHAT ELSE IS THIS MAN WILLING TO
DO TO BECOME A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS?
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
PEOPLE MADE FUN OF THIS.
I FOUND THIS INSPIRING.
PEOPLE HAVE A DREAM.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING TO GET IT.
I THOUGHT THIS SHOWED TOTAL
COMMITMENT TO GETTING ELECTED.
I ADMIRE THAT.
WOULD YOU SHAVE OUR EYEBROWS TO
GET ELECTED TO CONGRESS?
>> [LAUGHING].
THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON THE
SHOW.
I APPRECIATE IT.
THE TRUTH IS THE RESPONSE HAS
BEEN HUGE TO THIS VIDEO.
THE ONLY CRITICISM CAME THE FAR
LEFT WHO THINK IF HE STOP
SELLING GUNS THE 300 MILLION
GUNS ALREADY IN THE UNITED
STATES WILL DISAPPEAR.
ON THE FAR RIGHT, YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO PLAY COWBOYS
AND INDIANS IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
CLASS ROOMS.
THEY IMAGINE THAT EVERY SCHOOL
SHOOTER IS A TRAINED COMMANDO
AND EVERY TEACHER SHOULD BE AS
WELL.
THIS IS MEANT TO SOLVE A REAL
PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE GOING TO
GET ELECTED TO CONGRESS AND YOU
MAKE A FAIR POINT, YOU NEED TO
LEARN TO ANSWER THE QUESTION AT
HAND.
WOULD YOU SAVE YOUR EYEBROWS?
ARE YOU THAT COMMITTED?
>> I WANT TO HAVE A REAL
DISCUSSION.
>> Tucker: I AM HAVING A REAL
>> I CAME ON TO TALK ABOUT
SERIOUS ISSUES.
>> Tucker: YOU MACED YOURSELF IN
THE FAITH.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Tucker: I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> SCHOOL SHOOTINGS HAPPEN AT A
RANGE OF LESS THAN 8 FEET.
THIS IS WELL IN THE RANGE.
>> Tucker: YOU MACED YOURSELF --
HOLD ON.
YOU ARE ALMOST IN CONGRESS JUST
WITH THE SPEECH PATTERNS.
I AM IMPRESSED WITH THAT TOO.
>> I AM IMPRESSED WITH YOU TOO.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANYTHING YOU
WOULD NOT DO TO GET THIS JOB?
>> THAT'S NOT A RELEVANT
QUESTION.
>> Tucker: HOW COMMITTED ARE
YOU?
>> I WANTED TO DISCUSS SCHOOL
SAFETY.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY HAS 3 THINGS --
>> Tucker: NO, YOU JUST STAGED A
REALITY SHOW.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THIS IS THE LAST LINE OF
DEFENSE.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THERE IS A GUNMAN COMING INTO
THE CLASSROOM.
>> Tucker: RUBBER BULLETS?
YOU ARE NOT ANSWERING THE
QUESTION.
YOU ARE QUALIFIED FOR CONGRESS
ALREADY.
YOU ARE LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE UP
THERE.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THIS IS A SERIOUS POLICY
ISSUE.
WE WILL DISCUSS SERIOUS POLICY.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE UNBELIEVABLE.
SAYING THE MAN WHO MACED HIMSELF
IN THE FACE.